die Unzufriedenheit mit der Regierung
sie wächst sogar der ehemalige
Bundespräsident Joachim Gauck hat nun
deutliche Worte gefunden zur Gefühlslage
der deutschen
deshalb brauchen wir kraftvolle
politische Führung die gleichzeitig im
Stande ist das was sie im Sinn hat und
tun wird auch den Menschen so zu
erklären dass sie es wirklich verstehen
und wir haben im Moment so ein volatiles
Situation das eben sehr viele Menschen
das Vertrauen verloren haben und darum
brauchen wir ganz klar gesprochen nicht
nur die Ansage der zeitenwände die
unglaublich wichtig war sondern wir
brauchen auch eine Politik die dieser
Ansage entspricht
deutliche Worte über die wir sprechen
wollen bei uns im Studio ist jetzt unser
Bild meinungsschef Philipp Pia top schön
dass du hier bist Philipp man hat den
Eindruck Joachim Gauck spricht und alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hören ihm zu ja
Joachim Gauck schafft es eigentlich
immer wieder die richtigen Worte zu
finden und dadurch dass er sich auch
relativ selten in die Debatte einlässt
ist es umso kraftvoller aber das ist
natürlich nicht nur eine Frage der
Seltenheit sondern bei Joachim Gauck ist
es auch einfach die hohe Glaubwürdigkeit
das ist ein Mensch der selbst
jahrzehntelang für Demokratie gekämpft
hat der als großer Denker als wirklich
moralisch Integra Mensch bekannt ist und
wenn er die Regierung kritisiert
hinweist das war ja keine Abrechnung das
war wirklich kluge Anregung und Kritik
dann hören die Menschen zu und ich
glaube einigen Menschen wird auch
bewusst hoppala der aktuelle
Bundespräsident von dem hört man sowas
nicht und wenn man es hört dann glaubt
man es ihm auch gar nicht wo sind da die
genauen Unterschiede zwischen den beiden
ja das ist du fragst nach den
Unterschieden es ist fast schon schwerer
Gemeinsamkeiten zu finden also wir haben
auf der einen Seite eben den wirklich
aufrechten demokratiekämpfer Joachim
Gauck der auch selbst sehr schnell immer
erkannt hat wo die Gefahren liegen
beispielsweise 2014 hat er schon sehr
klar gewarnt russland hat die
Partnerschaft mit uns aufgekündigt
Russland ist eine Gefahr für uns darauf
müssen wir uns einstellen behielt
historisch recht wenn man sich an wo
Frank Walter Steinmeier sich befand wenn
man nach ihm sucht dann findet man ihm
eigentlich immer an einem Ort auf der
falschen Seite der Geschichte
beispielsweise zu Russland da hat er
2015 beispielsweise davon gesprochen
dass also er hat von Putin verstehen und
Kiew verstehen gesprochen so als könnte
man vergleichen wenn Menschen die
demokratische Ukraine unterstützen und
den mörderischen Diktator Putin er hat
der NATO säbelrassel vorgeworfen der
NATO die uns jetzt beschützt er hat
immer wieder davon gesprochen dass es
keine Sicherheit gegen Russland geben
dürfe so doch natürlich wir sind nur
sicher wenn wir uns gegen Russland
Stellen nicht mit Russland und diese
dieses Regime uns infiltriert so wie es
die SPD infiltriert hat und auch beim
Iran er hat 2019 noch die mullerregime
Glückwünsche geschickt und im Namen
meiner Landsleute gratuliert dieses
mullerregime das war es ja auch damals
schon das prügelt gerade Studentin von
der Straße also Steinmeier hat sich so
oft geirrt wie kein anderer Politiker
hat jegliche moralische Glaubwürdigkeit
verspielt und dass dieser Mann jetzt
aktuell im Schloss Bellevue sitzt das
ist einfach fatal was erwartest du von
ihm auf ihn wächst ja auch der Druck und
auch die Kritik wird immer lauter jetzt
ganz deutliche Worte auch von Gauck
glaubst du dass er irgendetwas ändern
wird dass er es zumindest adressieren
wird dass er irgendwie Stellung beziehen
wird oder ist das einfach so dass der
Bundespräsident den wir haben fertig aus
ja ich glaube leider letzte eigentlich
hätte Frank-Walter Steinmeier am 24
februar an dem Tag des Kriegsbeginns
zurücktreten müssen das wäre glaube ich
das einzig anständige gewesen
stattdessen stattdessen hat er sich
wochenlang Zeit gelassen und hat dann
Fehler eingeräumt hat aber gesagt wir
alle haben uns geirrt und dann muss ich
sagen nein wir alle haben uns nicht
geirrt sondern ganz viele Menschen haben
sich nicht geirrt haben vor der
russischen Gefahr gewarnt er hat sie
verharmlost und hat sich mit Putin
eingelassen
ich erwarte eigentlich nichts mehr von
Frank-Walter Steinmeier weil von
jemandem der so oft falsch lag kann man
nicht erwarten dass er plötzlich doch
diesen politischen Anstand wieder findet
den er vor langem verloren hat es wäre
richtig es wäre richtig gewesen wenn die
Union damals ein Gegenkandidaten
aufgestellt hätte leider hat man
Frank-Walter Steinmeier und der SPD
kampfloses Feld geräumt jetzt hat man
halt die Quittung dafür befinden wir
befinden uns in einer Kriegssituation
wir befinden uns in einer Energiekrise
und wir haben einen Bundespräsidenten
der dazu einfach nichts beitragen kann
sagt Philipp unser bildmeinungschef
vielen Dank für Deinen Besuch im Studio
[Musik]